joining us once again on the program the
armed forces minister james heapey
minister always good to have you on the
programme and as always lots for us to
discuss so let's let let's start shall
we with the kind of the overview of
where the conflict is currently the dod
and the mod seem to be an agreement that
the russians have made precious little
advance over the past week but i'm
wondering whether or not you are
concerned about what we've just seen in
the past few years in la viv what
appears to be the use of cruise missiles
to take out part of the airport facility
yeah i mean i think that's exactly right
niall that on the sort of macro level
when you look at the whole map the
russians are making very very little
progress and yet they continue to expend
a significant amount of military
resource
and
that is great credit to the resistance
the ukrainians are putting up
but on the sort of on the the sort of
smaller more local level what's going on
in mario paul is a cause for huge
concern the city is uh under a level of
barrage that is utterly terrifying and
disastrous for the population that
remains there the ukrainian mps that
visited me here in the ministry of
defence yesterday uh were telling me
that maybe 90 of the city is is now
being uh affected um and as you say you
know the there are now two strikes into
western ukraine the air base last week
and uh and strikes nov last night um so
whilst there's no macro progress
we're very concerned about the suffering
of the people in mario paul and other
cities that are under siege in the east
and the fact that ukrainian supply lines
are starting to be attacked in the west
it it certainly looks that there has
been a tactic of blanket bombardment
when it comes to mario paul in terms of
the russian strategy there you'll have
heard just in the past couple of minutes
though
in martha's report the russian
ambassador to to the united nations
denying any russian involvement in what
happened in that theater in mario paul
what is our intelligence telling us
about responsibility
i don't know how the russian ambassador
sleeps at night because you know he sits
there he stands there and he says that
to your correspondent that it is
it is clear as day what's happening in
in mario the russians are
indiscriminately
using uh artillery and missile strikes
to
um to destroy a city that they were
unable to take militarily and the
resistance that remains in there is
courageous the problem is is that mario
paul is probably the worst it's the one
that we're most concerned about but
actually um there's not dissimilar
things happening in kharkiv
as well and other faces besides um this
is a barbaric tactic the russians have
failed to do this militarily they
thought that they could do it in days
and what it looks like they're going to
try to do is to encircle these cities
and just then use artillery uh and
missile strikes in order to
to um to force the ukrainians into
submission but the ukrainians so no sign
of doing that and that's to their
enormous credit
um mr [ __ ] you and i have spoken enough
uh enough times that i know that you
choose your words very carefully so just
to pick you up in some of the things
that you said there barbaric tactics you
know it's clear as day what the russians
are doing there how does the russian
ambassador to the u.n sleep at night is
this now not the point for us to do what
the american president has done
and call vladimir putin what he
apparently is a war criminal a murderous
dictator a pure thug
well i mean i've
not pulled my punches when i've been on
your um on your show previously and i
think that the evidence that is
uh that is being gathered points very
much towards uh war crimes being
committed in ukraine and the culpability
for war crimes sits absolutely with the
leader of the russian government the man
who decided to do all of this in the
first place but the other point to make
and it's an important point to make is
that it's not just putin who ends up
being responsible for war crimes as and
when the evidence is gathered and people
are held to account every single person
in the military of chain of command
cannot just hide behind the line of
their only following orders they too are
involved in the prosecution of war
crimes in ukraine this is uh a stay
on uh on the russian nation and i know
because i can i see information about
some of the questions that russians are
asking on on on search platforms um you
know russians are
questioning whether or not the behavior
of their president and their armed
forces um is quite how it's being
presented to them on the russian media
and the answer is it's not their russia
the russian armed forces are letting the
russian people down their president is
letting the russian people down
given what we we've seen in mario paul
and indeed as you mentioned in a lot of
other places around ukraine it does
perhaps feel like we're putting the cat
before the horse but people are
beginning to talk about
how the conflict may well come to an end
and discussions seem to be in part
centering around the west you know the
united kingdom france the americans and
others somehow guaranteeing ukraine's
safety in the future i mean isn't that
just nato membership by another name
i don't think so i mean i think that
we've got to be we've got to be clear
that this
can't go on indefinitely that the thing
that all of us want
is not the the the endless arming of the
ukrainians so that they can resist as
necessary as that is for as long as the
fighting continues we don't want the
ukrainians to uh have to lose or to give
up their country but what we do need
clearly is a situation in which the two
sides meet and come to some sort of
arrangement if the west has a role to
play alongside others beyond the region
in brokering that piece and
offering something that uh that the
ukrainians and the russians can live
with that's fine but what i absolutely
don't think we should do and i've heard
some uh around the west suggest this is
that somehow ukraine should be pressured
to give up the donbass or to uh to to
give up its claim on the crimea those
are decisions entirely for president
zielenski and his government uh it's not
for the west to trade away ukrainian
sovereignty
i do want to speak about piano fairies
in just a second but finally just on the
on this topic
what are we to make of the fact that
that that a prank caller you know a
foreign agent was able to spend eight
nine minutes on a video call with the
secretary of state for defense at a time
when you know we are we are actively
assisting another country in its war
well i think that the secretary of state
has asked some pretty tough questions of
the department as to how that was able
to happen he acknowledges very much that
it shouldn't have done but ben is
um
is a guy that understands uh threat very
well he spent a long time as our
nation's security minister before he was
promoted to be the secretary of state he
was acutely aware that he was on uh
microsoft teams call
and therefore uh he would not ever uh
disclose any sensitive details on a
platform that can be very easily
intercepted and listened into
and the call therefore was
pretty bland i think from what ben was
explaining to me last night and when the
call started to ask more pointed
questions about
our intentions militarily in the region
um ben knew full well that that's not
the sort of question that anybody would
normally ask uh on teams uh and so he
became pretty suspicious and terminated
the court
and let's talk then um ferries a huge
story and on any other day would would
be our lead story at what point did
piano ferries if at all at what point
did they inform the government that they
were about to take what frankly some
people are describing as you know
employer relations from the 19th century
yeah it's disgraceful i i mean to be
honest with you now as far as i know
from um colleagues around government uh
they i don't think the government got
much more noticed than the employees of
piano did and my great friend robert
courts the transport minister was in the
commons yesterday and i could see from
the expression on his face just how
angry he was at the way that piano had
handled this um most importantly for the
people who were fired but actually just
it's shoddy to to to do that and to not
give the department for transport and
you notice the fact you're going to do
it because
he would have wanted i think to have
been involved in a discussion to try to
persuade piano to do things differently
is it the case then that there is pretty
much nothing that can be done then from
a government perspective about those 800
individuals it's time for them to you
know i don't know seek employment
tribunals
so sadly it is the case that the
government cannot force an employer to
continue to employ people that the
employer has said it doesn't want to to
employ
but ordinarily in these situations a
company would come to the government in
fact
often companies come to the government
way before they actually need to do
anything because they're just constantly
lobbying for more support in piano's
case it seems that they had made their
decision entirely under their own steam
uh and the dft were told about the same
time as the people working for piano
absolutely horrendous way to treat their
staff
there's and i know there's a lot of
anger amongst ministerial colleagues in
the department for transport they're
seeing what they can do to try to make
the situation better um but the reality
is is that pno have made a commercial
decision um and as much as we disagree
with it um i i fear that for those uh
for those workers um they've been badly
let down by their employer minister i've
got to let you go so you can answer this
as quickly or as slowly as you like um
you know we gave them 10 million pounds
in terms of furlough money can we get
that back from piano ferries
oh no i don't know i mean it sounds like
exactly the sort of thing that um that
if i were the treasury i would be asking
for but um but i i don't know exactly
how these things work i'm afraid i'm
sorry you've got enough on your plate as
a minister always good to have you in
the program thanks for being with me
thank you very much